remember from julia computing giving a
talk about julia for data analysis thank
you
so i've been if imposter here talking
about julia at a plaything conference
but i'll try and talk about how julia
works with python and in fact i'm giving
his talk you know ipython notebook she's
a good sign I don't actually have any
data of my own to talk about so here's a
nice little plot I've dug up of which I
couldn't find the raw data it's a
probability it's from study on accept
parole success for prisoners and so
probability of parole during over the
time of day and so you can see is a nice
drop off before lunch
so hopefully that doesn't look a bad
leak for my talk so what is Julia it's
well fairly simply is a dynamic high
performance language I originally
designed protective computing but it
started becoming much more broad these
syntax I guess is very heavily
influenced by Python with a smattering
of MATLAB and a few other things so
here's a nice example I've got here it's
as you can see the main sort of scene
tactic differences from Python which are
surprisingly contentious for like if you
read hacker news basically rather than
significant whitespace use an end block
and it's one based indexing but if you
can live with that
which is actually turns out to be very
easy then it you'll pick it up very
quickly if you've familiar with Python
so why Julia
why would you want to use it
fundamentally if you want to write fast
efficient code in one language so you
don't want to write have to write
something in Python and then dump it
into C or Fortran etc so avoid what we
term the two language problem the other
really nice thing about it makes it very
easy to sort of peek under the hood you
can see what is actually going on at
each step of computation why it's slow
how you can make it faster etc for
example most of julia itself is written
in julie
very surprisingly small bit of it as
actually written anything else and at
each stage of the computation you can
step through it and go right here's what
it's doing as it gets converted from the
code I wrote to actually machine code
also it's free which is always good and
it's presently fun and finally it plays
very nicely with sort of existing tool
chains and that's certainly improving as
we go so the sort of single most
important things to know about Julia
firstly a types so roughly analogous to
Python classes but somewhat different in
the sense of well firstly every object
has a type so the type of one is a
function the type of a function is a
function and a type of a type is a
datatype we can declare new types just
with a type of what's called a type
keyword and then you can get straight
objects of those types firstly the
modern really important things to say is
that unlike many dynamic languages types
in julia usually defined types that just
as fast as the built-in types there's no
reason that they there's no they're not
like second-class citizens that you have
to then go hack in to get to make fast
yet to go so use all these lower levels
of constructions you can just use the
user-defined types straight up the other
very important thing to know about Julia
and where it diverges significantly from
other object-oriented languages is that
julia functions don't belong julia
functions are generic and they don't
belong to up type so we define a
function here so we can call this
defines a function it does two things if
it's the argument is a floating-point
number
it prints X as a float and if it's an
integer if it's something else
so this is a different slightly
different syntax it's sort of a nice
one-line syntax for writing functions
which becomes very useful when you have
to write a lot of them like this and
this double colon is
is what's called the type specification
or type specifies the types that is
acceptable for the input and so if we
call it with a a floating-point number
we get the one is a float and then when
it's an integer and so as I mentioned
unlike traditional object-oriented
languages functions don't belong to a
particular type so what that means is
that also we have what's called multiple
dispatch and that dispatch how a
function how a method is particularly a
particular method so each one of these
is a method inside the function which
method is chosen is determined by all
the arguments the function not just the
first one so it's not you go so which
makes it very can make it much more
powerful to write certainly certain
objects so for example here we have a
expression we can add some more methods
so that each for these two these takes
two arguments so the first one takes a
float64 an integer the second one takes
any real numbers
and the last one is a generic method
that takes any object whatsoever so if
we each one of those then dispatches to
the correct method as you would hope
purely based on the arguments and for
example then if you want to show how
that particular object is printed Wiest
so for that bars object we defined
earlier now this is handled by the show
function so and show is a generic
function and it's made up of this
different methods and we can view all
those by typing show so methods of show
and so as you can see there's 105 of
them and each so each so when you call
show on a particular object it looks up
see which one and the first thing you'll
notice is that every most of these are
two methods
tooting to object to argument methods
and what this means is that most of
these show methods taken on what's
called an i/o object as a first argument
so this leads lets you to write two
different places so you can write to
stand it out you can write to buffers
files etc and there's a generic for back
seat lizard you know
method called which takes a single
argument which again just prints it to
the standard out so if we want to
overwrite show we first import it and
then we assign a new method for this
base object and then when we now display
it it just prints I'm using a new method
so that's the rough idea of multiple
dispatch that we can exploit this and
this becomes very powerful especially we
start doing a much more complicated
scheme so a really nice example is
matrix multiplication so if you have
trying to do a matrix multiplication we
can have different matrix types so it
really has like this right there's a
standard dense matrix that sparse
matrices there's dad and so the
structure matrices like diagonals and
tri diagonals and each of these can then
dispatch onto the correct severe
multiplying two types of matrices you
can dispatch then onto the fastest
matrix multiplication method you don't
need to fall back to a stem you know
standard triple four loop method of
doing it
the final do the other really sort of
important ingredient in julia which
makes it fast is what's just-in-time
compilation so basically every time you
call a function it's just in time
compiled down to the two down to sort of
machine instructions and then is then
executed so functions are the
fundamental unit at which all dual their
methods are compiled and so the first
tip this when people's first start using
julia they'll complain it's slow and
then this first the single fast easiest
way to improve your code is to put it
all inside a function and then you call
it and then suddenly it's magically
faster the other one is the other trick
is somewhat a little more evolved but to
get the most out of jeweler and
particularly how it works internally use
the trick called type inference so when
it starts the compilation process it
goes through and tries to figure out
what actually the type of each of each
variable is in your in your program your
function and so to do that efficiently
you need to sort of get a you develop a
knack over time of writing what's called
like stable code so that as the program
executes the type of a variable doesn't
change and some what you see this for
certain things for example this is an
example why for example square root of
negative 1 doesn't promote to a complex
type because otherwise we would be
converting if you when the compiler were
to see a square of at a floating-point
number
it wouldn't know whether it will be out
the result would be a a floating-point
number or a complex number so you need
to precipitously for any complex and
this pops up in a few other cases
another one is that integer arithmetic
by default doesn't unlike Python it
doesn't promote to big integers to up to
precision beginners because otherwise
you wouldn't be able to have fast
integer arithmetic and so for that
reason we can get you know integer
arithmetic is the same as it would be in
C because there's no none of this
branching to see if it's if you've acted
it you know if you've excellently gone
out of the size your type but need to
promote this big object the other neat
trick which I won't touch on too much is
meta programming and this is something
is really powerful and it comes from
sort of its list background the idea is
basically that you can actually write
julia code with so julie you can
actually manipulate julia expressions
with julia itself so if you put we can
sort of quote an expression using this
colon syntax then puts it in a string
then it gives you expression object
which we can then and the other useful
thing is then macros which essentially
transform expressions which operate on
on expressions and transform them and
then execute them so these are prefixed
swill glue that so if you familiar with
Python decorate I mean obviously very
similar to place and decorators but much
more powerful and how they work because
you can actually manipulate the code
inside a very simple one is simply the
time macro which tells you exactly how
long you think it takes to run and this
is a good example of the just-in-time
compilation because you can see that
took ten twentieth of a second and the
next time you run it the time is much
lot much quicker because now we're at
the function I defined earlier has been
just-in-time compiled and you can
actually see what that expense what the
your code it's doing we can expand the
macro code as you can see there's the it
sort of essentially is calculating the
time the current time computes the
computes the expression and then
computes the difference in time prints
it and returns you the value actually
computed about back out and these are
quite powerful cuz as I said earlier you
can sort of view all these stages the
compilation process so if we that
function we defined earlier this is the
first stage is this sort of type
inference process and so you can see
it's a bit of a mess here but you can
see what happened it's sort of tags each
expression with what it thinks the type
will be and then it step the next step
down as it steps down to what's called
the LVM intermediate representation
which is essentially these the level
that the LVM back-end manipulates
expressions and does alts optimizations
out and then finally you can actually go
all the way down to what is the assembly
that was generated by that resulting
expression if you go to reading assembly
and macros are really quite powerful
they let you do all sorts of tricks
which you would otherwise be quite a
which very much make it less you also
very tricked so and very elegant example
is this is what's called program called
a package called jump which essentially
is a mathematical optimization package
sort of germane specifically mature
optimization programs and so you specify
your probation problem in this language
and then you can then lets you call all
sorts of different optimization package
like groovy SEAPLEX etc automatically
without having to then change your
program to change the different back in
optimizing optimizers and then finally
which is the rest of my talk I'm going
to talk about the packages so julie has
a very extensive and growing so
third-party package ecosystem obviously
and very easy to add packages just buy a
package dot add within julia and pack
truly packages in case you ever
searching for them are typically softly
suffix with a jl extension which makes
them very easy to search for which is
actually good at deciding to
you search for something Jael you
usually get the first Julie first Google
hit so the next one so the topic my talk
was talking about the Julia for data
science I mean talk about some of the
packages that are particularly powerful
for Julia using Julia in this sort of
setting a very simple one is what's
called distributions package so as a
name which suggests that's essentially
provides support for different
probability distributions and it's a
very elegant object based structure so
each class of distributions is a type so
if you want to gamma a gamma
distribution you just construct a gamma
object various and then all the various
methods then can be applied directly to
these objects so you can feed the means
the bare answers and then CDF's
etc and then call random number and
compute random numbers from those
distributions there's also some very
basic some simple estimation
functionality so if you want to fit them
the result of those random numbers to a
gamma distribution you can compete that
or if you want to see what it how could
a normal distribution that would fit you
can accept I do that sort of thing so we
can pass types directly these functions
as well and then see one of the nice
things about them is under the hood
these distributions are defined as
what's known as an immutable type which
lets you do all sorts of sort of
optimizations which aren't really
possible in all the languages so for
example allows sort of because it knows
the immutable it's an immutable type it
knows it can be represented exactly by
those two fields it's those two
parameters you can do things like it can
allocate those sort of distribution in
the stack and so essentially there's no
overhead to creating and destroying
these objects unlike many other
languages we if you create a new object
particular class it has to then allocate
the object then destroy the object when
you're done etc and there's also lots of
efficient methods for multivariate
distribution so multivariate is
particularly sort Northup distributions
where it will pre compete cholesky
factors or also exploit knowing
structure so if we want to
construct a multivariate normal with the
diagonal covariance you can see it's
great to what's known as a zero mean
normal die so it knows it has a zero
mean it also hasn't there's a diable
covariance so it can then exploit that
structure to do the computations much
faster than it would if it was you had a
full dance covariance structure we can
obviously then compute random numbers
from that distribution the other packet
next package which is probably of most
use and sort of standard data
manipulation is what's called data
frames so as the varies provides sort of
standard tabular data functionality of
heterogeneous columns very similar to a
data frame or pandas in Python those are
the things so we can load the package so
there's various functions so retailer
for loading CSV files there's a read RDA
for loading compressed the RDA format
there's also a nice packages for
importing there's sort of extra plugins
for importing from straight from
databases so skew light post grades etc
and then we construct them but you can
also construct them directly from
vectors so if we construct the data
frame so it's a constructor from various
it's from three different vectors or
alternatively it also supports a
nullable elbow thing objects via these
na values and so we use this at data
macro for letter you specify any objects
in the vectors and you'll notice here
we're not actually restricted so using
sort of numbers or strings in the data
in the columns we can actually pass any
jeweler object in there so for example
in this column I've got a column i've
got a column of distributions so a good
way to get sample data sets is this our
data sets package which just loads the
all that Olly has all the data sets that
come with wrapped up in R so this is the
standard IRS data set which almost
everybody sort of drummed into
statisticians from there when they start
learning and you can do a sort of
standard very centered item each place
and very similar syntax to pandas
instead of strings for index we use
what's this julia has symbols which are
prefixed with a colon so you don't have
to you know put everything in quotes use
these symbols so so subsetting gives you
a column you can also do standard row
column indexing and you can subset by
indexing via and you can so the dot here
the dot in case you're wondering that
dot less than is sort of a vectorized
form of the less than sign so if you're
taking since vectors copy compared less
than exactly the dot means that it's a
element-wise less then and we also
support sort of rough sort of similar
the what's known is this sort of Hadley
wickham sort of split apply combined
approach so what we have here is four by
this by function you could have the IRS
data set you have the species of the
name of the variable you want to split
by and then you can apply a function to
each of those so the sub data sets so
this short end this sort arrow is of a
lambda lets you specify anonymous
functions and so you can see here we
have whoops but there and they computed
the mean of a is column the next one
other very elegant package is this
so for plotting julie does actually come
with any in bill plotting software as of
yet sort of we're letting him there's
various plotting packages out there
where i'll give you an overview of two
of them this talk i guess we'll see how
it goes to which one will win and then
eventually i guess we're all wrapping
incorporate into us standard library but
the most popular one is an very powerful
one is this gadfly is it takes a little
while to get going unfortunately cause
of all the compilation going on the
background because because it does
actually quite a lot so roughly speaking
it's inspired by this sort of grammar of
graphics that also used by the ggplot2
package in our
so it's very simple here we passed an x
and a y as a because I as a X my vectors
and it gives you an SVG output it also
is very nice it's an interactive SVG
output so you can zoom in and out and
drag things around so this is just a
simple SVG file with a bit of JavaScript
tacked on to it so if you save this if I
save this a file you you know everyone
can you will still get the same
interactive features so it's very nice
and portable a very powerful scheme it
also plays very nicely we've data frame
so if I have that iris data set from
before we get sort of very nice colored
pictures and of course we can
the geometry so here we have you specify
the coordinates so in this sort of
grammar of graphics construction you
specify the coordinates by keyword
argument so the first coordinate is
sepal width why is this equal length and
then your color which is one of these
other coordinates is the specified by
species if we could also change that for
example to petal width and then you get
a nice gradient color there as well the
geometry is what's different should and
then the other so suppose these
different facets so the first one is the
the geometry of the coordinates the
other one is these geometries so you
passed these extra arguments so a simple
one you passed a line plot passed
chioma's on so these genome Dex is a
line it also supports very simple
statistical functionality such as
histogram and density so we get these
density histogram density plots with
variables and also supports lots of
other things nice things like themes so
you can get consistent themes scale DB
scale act so log scales etc and units on
your axes which is very nice
and so the next package so GLM provides
a linear in generalize alidium model
framework for julia it's roughly similar
to it's very uses of sort of a similar
formula syntax to are for anyone who's
encountered that before so this tilde
sort of does a little bit of macro
trickery in the background so lets you
so quotes this sort of expression C as a
so we can write its we can use this sort
of very form very similar formula syntax
it's slightly different because of how
the the operator precedence changes from
our but we can do a fit linear model so
rather than calling the function
directly we call the object type and
then I call and fit and that will fit
our sort of simple linear model to the
data and then of course we can then use
that model to predict new observe to get
the fitted values by predict so we'll
sign that to a new column in IRS and
then we can put the results there pretty
good first the observed a lot of nice
axes there and so that gives you some
idea of the difference having our
predictions are and then finally one of
the very nice package these if you've
ever used mixed effects models so sort
of the current workhorse one is this le
me for packaging art but other actually
has recently moved to writing all these
coding julia and this the result is this
mixed models package so for loads and
quite a nice reasonable sized dataset so
this is a I believe this is dad a
student evaluation data and so it's
73,000 rows and we can fit so it
supports this very similar syntax to our
we specify the random effects by this
bar syntax and it should take a few
seconds but you can fit quite very nice
and very large actually complicated
models in this
so that took seven seconds to fit what
is actually a reasonably complicated
model these are mixed effects models you
know how complicated these things can
get and that took seven seconds of time
but I was because it was compiling it we
run it again then much quicker so other
sort of statistics and data packages
that you view interest there's lots of
hypothesis testings Baathist tests
kernel density estimators then like sort
of penalize regression so lassoo and GL
m-net are all supported very well and
it's growing and growing and growing so
the other thing i want to talk about is
how julia can interact with our
languages so obviously as a new language
it can't compare with sort of the sheer
breadth of libraries written in our and
python and those sort of things but it
makes it very very easy to interface
with these the nature of the way makes
it very very easy that you face with
these so every simplest ones being see
you can has a very very similar
interface for calling see it exists in c
libraries so here I'm calling the the
Lib am in the math library calling the
power function it takes two arguments
the takes the it takes two arguments the
bottom and exponent both of which
doubles and then it returns a double
argument as a result and so if we do
that it simply then calls out very
easily there's also very other low-level
functions which you can use to interface
with C C function for calling creating C
compatible function pointers and then
things like unsafe store and I'd say
fluid for loading by binary blobs
straight of digital there and then once
is what's really neat is when you can PI
this with like meta programming it makes
it very easy for generating like for
wrapping existing libraries you don't
have to then type out all these
individually
you just have a program that generates
all these sequel statements and then
gives you a code gives your resulting
from the library get a very nice wrapper
for existing libraries being PI thing we
obviously want to talk about PI call so
start up PI call it actually initializes
a Python interpreter in the background
and then we can evaluate sort of strings
in Python so this is
just calling up license to execute
Python statement and then evaluating it
and returning it as a jeweler object so
it returns the jewel Python lists get
converted back to a jeweler array it's
also a slightly nicer interface is PI
import statement so if we run PI import
macro crating you truly a module mass
and then imports all the Python Python
functions in that into this julia
library so we can math dot sign is is
that simply is wrapper around the PI
object which we can actually call
directly and so it's the parser julia
number gets path to the price add
function calls evaluate something if
it's converted back to the julia all
sort of seamlessly so if there's imagine
julia type so for things like
dictionaries and arrays and numbers
things of strings
everything's converted automatically if
there's not you get a it's called a pi
object wrapper one of them only sort of
slight hassle with this is that Julia
doesn't support overloading that dot
operator so we can't call d dot to
integral so instead you have to use it
slowly slightly ugly get index get index
notation but nevertheless it works quite
well so we're calling me this is the
same as calling the dot two integral
numpy so numpy arrays actually is
exactly the same memory layout as julie
arrays so we can actually pass so you
can convert them directly between the
two in fact I think it's Julie arrays
you can pass directly to numpy without
any copying so if you had create
inspector a julia numpy sees it it
doesn't have to allocate a new array i
think the other way back though it does
have delicate and your age you to the
intricacies of getting all these things
to work well but it makes it very easy
to call some numb python have so
existing numpy code or if you've got
code it uses numb by two you know can
use julia julia objects and you can even
pass julia functions directly to Python
functions which accept lambdas so so pay
to optimize we're passing this jewel
anonymous function which calls so with
this Julie anonymous function it passes
the SyFy sou ttan with initial I
starting one sliding value of one and
then does some mutant iterations and
then gives us the number back so it's
very seamless there's a great example of
someone I was going to put in a you know
having a factorial statement which calls
alternates between jeweler and Python
all the way down to give you you're a
very inefficient implementation of
factorial but I decided to leave it out
finally pipe lot you can also load my
plot live by this PI import but there's
this pie plot package which is just
makes a little bit nicely if it's so and
let's use maps I've got lots of map
fault loop syntax you can use it almost
directly translated directly into julia
so if you're in consider yourself per
since every plotting package you know
this is always this big learning curve
into learning i'm plotting all the
intricacy for plotting package you just
want to take your map pot live large and
use it straight now julia it works
basically exactly as you expect it would
so we've got a Julia - Julia vectors and
then we pass some straight in time yes
ma'am
plot function which is calling
matplotlib and you get your sinusoidally
modulated sinusoid and you see it's all
it's actually giving you a Python object
in the background but is a it's printing
it out here and then there's also this
pi julia package which essentially is
does the opposite and does the opposite
bike loading this pi call internally in
operating backwards so you can call call
the two functions between themselves the
other one being data you necessarily
need sometimes come across are so i'll
call as you would expect
does operate it very similar to pi call
so this is an our input macro which is
very similar so you can load
unfortunately there's a jeweler object
called base so i can't load it as base
but i can load it as our base and then
we think also there julia functions so
the if you familiar with the C function
constructs vectors in R and so we can
call it directly
it gives us an our object back we don't
return Julie or objects natively because
theirs has a lot of fancy wrapping so
like it's na handling does by essential
value that stuff does all sorts of
trickery so it's easier just to keep
them as are objects in this case they
don't match up quite as nicely as Python
does and then I'll get index work so we
can get the the first the eight element
or the B element of this obvious our
vector and plotting packages work
remarkably well so we can call this so
I'm just sitting the this just sets the
output to use SVG and then we can paths
we can call the our graphics so the this
is calling your standard our plot
function unfortunately if you've ever
used our in any detail you'll know it
does some very weird one of its quirks
is what's called a non-standard
evaluation which means that unlike any
other language it actually looks at the
arguments you said what you pass into a
function affects it not just their
values and it's very hard to replicate
that in Julie elegant links because
simply and Julie is much more standard
mints evaluation and so usually when you
do a plot of a vector in are you would
see it would just put an X here because
that's the bit name of the variable you
put into it but of course we can't Julia
doesn't have any way of giving it the
name of the vector that you pass to it
so instead of print out all the values
which is somewhat ugly the other problem
is that has lots of syntax which doesn't
match up so it has these square brackets
in double square brackets and then it
uses dots in variable names which
obviously conflicts with the Julia
syntax so instead what there is is this
very elegant way called non-standard
string literals so you can view these as
sort of somewhat similar to Python
ipython magics but on steroids so what
this does is calls the so when you
prefix a string with a some sort of
substring of variables it actually is
calling a macro which changes the code
to do something else so here what I'm
doing is calling a plot dollar on dollar
XO dollar it just does substitution so
whenever dollar is invalid our syntax
which
is basically only when it appears
between two variable two symbols you can
it will do substitution of the
corresponding geriatric Juli variable so
remember X back here was a vector so we
do do this and it calls the so it's
essentially passing it as R and then
converts the Julia syntax and you can
actually view what that we can use that
see what that does we can do expand so
you can see what it's actually doing is
calling me up it's substituting the
dollar X for the the this variable and
then calls the our parser on that and
this makes it very easy to and then it
returns an our object back which in this
case is the plot well actually is the
trans nothing back but it gets pizza
plot out in the plot out and you can
actually also substitute you'd have to
use our Julia variables you can put hold
Jule their expressions in this dollar
syntax so I can plot Julia functions
directly simply by passing in simply by
passing in putting between this dollar
so it makes it very seamless to
implement to interoperate between the
two so if we load this so now we're
using the our data sets package to load
the iris dataset into Julia
loading the we load the ggplot2 package
in our and then call the ggplot2 ggplot
function with the iris dataset loaded in
and then use the various variable names
and the resulting object gets so this
gets converted to an our data frame and
then we can then just use that as we
would a usual our data frame to give you
a nice ggplot2 plots and finally we can
also then fit to the linear models as
well so you have things like LM yeah we
can pass variables directly there pass
the pass the object data frame through
variable and then we get this victor
back and then you can do things like
the variable is there we go
and then you can then obviously model is
that opt our object which you can then
get its particular vectors back now if
you want to convert that to a jeweler
object we can call our copy which will
then just convert it to a nice julier
array I think if we convert this it'll
gives you a dictionary there we get a
dictionary dictionary back of the
corresponding our object okay and then
as similar to hi Julia there is also our
Julia which then does the opposite for
calling Julia from our was actually our
Julia - is sort of a work in progress I
think they're not Val Venis but they
sort of think all internally caught
users all this - from Julia
and similarly there's other languages so
Java call the interactively Java and all
the jvm languages see xx which is one of
these incredible things for writing
inline C++ so which is sort of sullen
developments a bit of a a bit impetuous
but the essentially you can because
clang and I drew Leah share the same
back end you can actually just call the
clang compiler on C++ code in London
Julia and I'll it'll convert it to and
give you the correct output and LVM call
is the other lets you actually call
directly inline LVM or even you can
write inline assembly so inline assembly
and dynamic languages is the way to go I
think future directions so we recently
got a large it's a bit of money from the
Moore Foundation to sort of further
expand on this sort of data processing
eco satisfied ecosystem and Julia and
we're trying to work on these ideas so
things like making the syntax for data
animation relation much more convenient
so I mentioned this right using macros
they can embed to the domain-specific
languages and Julia very easily so
that's sort of one thing we're exploring
so something similar to deep wire or
even like lincoln's the.net languages
and then obviously when i support more
backends so there's SQLite and Postgres
support
other things like s frames and Paco and
basically we also a lot of engineering
to make this things faster so really you
have to get the most out of this you
have to sort of leverage Julio's type
inference functionality and so that
means things like you have to improve
the speed of you so currently Union type
so data you know tap nullable data so it
can be an object or it can be an awl so
we have to make those reason we perform
and such that things can be fast and
then also work on these data modeling so
there's GLM's but we want to expand this
to the alby's computations out of core
give you sort of nice interfaces and
then also the support for distributed
computing so there's this sort of
compute framework which is a very
similar to like these sort of we're
working at the moment is this a day
basically add a computational shadow
like this in the in the vein of SPARC et
cetera okay thank you